One of the most powerful
features of Android,
since the start of the platform
has been the ability to deliver
timely notifications to users.
We're going to add a simple
one to our weather app.
This simple notification will show
the weather icon for the forecast,
the forecast text,
and the high and low
temperature for the day.
One of the key things we wanted
to point out is how not to be spammy
with our notification.
Our app will display, at most,
a single notification.
It really wouldn't make sense
if these notifications stacked up anyhow.
They don't display enough information
to give context.
The key thing with notifications
is to deliver a useful morsel
of information,
formatted in a standard way,
so that it harmonizes
with the rest of the system.
We'll start by adding a string
for the preference for the last time
we sent a notification to the user.
As well as a format string
for the body of the notification.
Let's implement the notification
inside of our sync adapter.
Our notification will be based upon
what is in the database.
So, we'll create projection
and column indices
values in our sync adapter,
for the weather id.
Description, max and min temperature,
let's add a function to notify us
of the weather.
We'll add some additional
constants up here.
One for day in mili's
and one so that we can use
the same notification ID.
Reusing the notification ID
means that our application will only
post at most one notification.
And then finally, we'll call this function
at a reasonable place
within our on perform
sync function within our sync adapter.
Inside of notify weather, we'll check
to see whether or not we've
actually shown notification that day.
If we haven't,
then we'll talk to the database.
Get a cursor for the current resolver
for the current day,
and then fetch the data,
but one thing we're not doing
is actually showing the notification.
Now all right, were getting near the end.
Implement a weather notification,
build our notification
using Notification Compat.builder
pointing to a Pending Intent built
by the v4 compatible, TaskStackBuilder,
and sent with the NotificationManager.
Hint: an explicit intent
to our main activity
is a good idea here.
There's lots of documentation
on this you'll want to read.